[Music]
morbius appeared first as an antagonist
in the amazing spiderman in 1971 and
eventually evolved into more of an
anti-hero if you're gonna run
do it now
for years before that marvel was
actually forbidden from using characters
considered more on the supernatural side
so it was a really big deal when morbius
finally made his debut there's something
inside of me
who wants to hunt
[Music]
and consume blood
he was part of a much darker turn within
marvel one that fortunately fans fully
embraced after all everyone loves a good
monster story
there's something about the character
that stoked people's imaginations
it really can grab a hold of you
that certainly did with me
see you in theaters
you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
and you control it
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
uh dr mike you and i should stay in
touch
i do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take
them are you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
[Music]
huh
[Music]